صوره ميسي مع كاس العالم مزيفه اومتيتي
يغادر مباراه فريقه باكيا واستقبال مميز
لسواريز في البرازيل هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
صوره ميسي الشهيره مع كاس العالم كسرت كل
الارقام المتعلقه بالتفاعل على السوشيال
ميديا لكن هذه الكاس الظاهره في الصوره هي
مزيفه وليست حقيقيه الكاس التي رفعها
اليوم مع زملائه تعود لشخصين كان في
الملعب وقضايا سته اشهر في صنعها كي تبدو
مثل الكاس الاصليه دي ماريا كان اللاعب
الوحيد الذي تفطنا للامر واشار اللقائدهم
ميسي الذي ضحك بعد بعد اكتشاف الامر كما
فحص طريقه من فيفا الكاس المحل ده قبل
ارجاعها لاصحابها
[موسيقى]
وفي عالم انستغرام يستعدوا ميسي ايضا
ليكون صاحب الاعلانات الاغلى على موقع
التواصل ويعد الاعلان على بروفايل رونالدو
نجم النصر السعودي هو الاغلى باكثر من
مليون دولار للمنشور الواحد لكن مع ارقام
التفاعل الرهيبه التي حققها ميسي بعد فوزه
بكاس العالم قد تقلب الموازين اذ يبلغ
الان سعر الاعلان على بروفايل ميسي نحو
مليون و700,000 دولار وهو رقم المرشح
للارتفاع بعد فوز الارجنتيني في كاس
العالم
الدعاء رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
جاني انفانتيرو للتضامن مع ثنائي نادي
ليتش الايطالي سام وناميت باندا بعد
تعرضهما لهتفه عنصريه ونشر انفنتينو فيديو
عبر حسابي على الانستغرام متمني ينتهي
بانتقف الغالبيه العظميه من المشجعين
لاسكات كل العنصريين مره واحده والى الابد
وكانهم ابتدي قد غادر المباراه الباكيا في
مشهد حزين عقب نهايه لقاء فريقه امام
لاسيو
في خبر
المميز من طرف الجماهير نادي الجديد
البرازيلي استشهد اكثر من 30,000 متفرج في
ملعب الفريق اثناء حفل تقديم النجم
الاوروجواينيه وكان سواريز غدا الواقع في
مدينه بورتو بعد انتهاء عقده مع نادي
طفولته ناسيونال ويبدا ان جيرمن مميزه في
الدرجه الممتازه بعد صعوده من الدرجه
الثانيه الموسم الماضي
[موسيقى]